Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Um man in Frankreich haben die jetzt die Wahl zwischen Macron und Le Pen.
Stell dir mal vor um Alice Weidel zu verhindern musst du Christian Lindner wählen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundsiebenundzwanzig vom zwölften April zwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Ja da sind wir wieder und ähm.
Was ist denn mit dem HTTP Statuscode vier zwei sieben.
Ist auch noch so eine Frage, ne,
diese Frankreich Geschichte, die macht einen schon irgendwie ein bisschen unrund oder? Also es ist äh noch mal so, wann sind diese Stichwahlen? Ist das schon in einer Woche dann?
Nächstes äh warte mal, warte, weiß ich nicht genau, da haben wir den Google.
Google oh heiliger Google spricht zu uns.
Von Google enttäuscht. Ich dachte, der steht jetzt einfach groß da.
Muss die allwissende Müllhalde fragen. Die wahr ist das.
Wann Stichwahl Frankreich?
Ich bilde mir ja schon wieder gerade ein irgendwie Internetgeschichte geschrieben zu haben. Stimmt aber wahrscheinlich nicht, weil äh in der persönlichen Erinnerung ist ja immer alles,
Wahrscheinlich auch von dir, ne, wenn du so über dich nachdenkst, denkst du ja auch mal, du bist der Größte und wenn dann mal die Fakten checkt so, dann
ergeben sich Aspekte und mir geht es auch so neulich äh äh twitterte jemand so ausm Amerika. Oh er hätte gerade herausgefunden, dass
die äh aus oh Gott, jetzt weiß ich gerade gar nicht, wie heißt du noch mal die auf ähm im Original?
Ähm Fraggar Rock heißt diese Serie.
Kenne ich nicht. Nee.
Kennst die Freddies nicht?
24. April, Stichwahl in Frankreich.
April okay. Du kennst die Fregels nicht, ist nicht dein Dance.
Was ist.
Ja, ja. So so so sind.
Die Fregels sind von von hier ähm wie heißen sie denn?
Ist das alles bei Disney, ist halt so ähm Jim Hansen und so weiter, genau.
Sesamstraße rum, ne?
Nee, ist nicht wirklich Sesamstraße, nochmal so ein.
Sind es die mit dem mein Name.
Nein, das sind nicht die mit dem. Die Fregels sind so kleine, putzige Lebewesen, die leben so unterirdisch und ähm,
und und und sind eigentlich irgendwie ganz lustig und man kann sich das mal angucken. Also falls du noch mal bereit bist dich,
War das wahrscheinlich auch Gespräch. Na ja und.
Bei mir nicht, bei dir, aber.
Wann ist Tim, wo wann kommt der Punkt? Ich war.
Kommt jetzt.
Wenn die allermeisten unserer Hörerinnen natürlich sich jetzt vor den Kopf haulen und sagen, alter Linus ey Fregels,
hast du überhaupt weißt du überhaupt irgendwas. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall die Fraglets leben halt in so einer kleinen Höhlenwelt und so weiter
Ohren sind irgendwie ganz putzig und ganz lustig und man kann sich das angucken. Und eine der äh wichtigen Figuren ist halt irgendwie und Margery ist halt so ein Müllhaufen.
Und in der deutschen Übersetzung von was in Deutschland einfach nur Fragges heißt, ist halt äh wird halt die allwissende Müllhalde genannt.
Immer wenn die nicht weiter wissen, dann gehen sie zu Margery und lassen sich irgendwie äh die Bilder erklären. Und.
Der deutschen Übersetzung,
ist es halt die allwissende Müllhalde und ich und jetzt kommt genau dieser,
der der der vermutlich falschen Selbsteinschätzung.
Du hast gedacht, du hättest die Wikipedia, die allwissende Müllhalde genannt.
Habe die Wikipedia schon immer die allwissenden Müllhalde genannt. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob ich das von irgendjemand anders.
Du bist wie ein Fregel, ey. Da hast du gedacht, du hättest die Wikipedia erwissen.
Ja, ich nenne die schon immer die allwissenden Müllheide. Ich jetzt äh tue ich das bloß schon so lange, dass ich halt irgendwie in dem Glauben bin,
dass ich wahrscheinlich der erste war, der das gemacht hat.
Obwohl es vermutlich irgendjemand anderes vor,
dass das dass ich das halt reingesetzt habe und dann kam halt irgendwie so ein Tweet, wo irgendjemand aus den USA meinte so
Ich habe gerade herausgefunden, dass irgendwie Margery irgendwie in Deutschland allwissende Müllhalde genannt wird und so weiter und dass das sozusagen das Äquivalent für Wikipedia ist und wie geil das denn ist.
Ja und ich dachte mir so, hm.
Weißt du, weißt du, in welcher Welt ich lebe, Tim? Ich lebe in einer Welt, in der ich mir am 1. April einen Wecker gestellt habe.
Frühmorgens und das Lego 10300 zu bestellen.
Zehn dreihundert. Was soll das sein?
Ist jetzt vorübergehend nicht auf Lager
und du wirst erblassen. Du wirst sowas von erblassen. Von meinem geilen Lego-Stück, was heute gekommen ist. Ja, das ist einfach so was von,
ich gebe ja ungern an, ne? Aber du bist einfach du wirst so erblassen. Die Zeitmaschine aus Zurück in die Zukunft.
Also die die echte.
Mit einer kleinen 1,2 Gigawatt Batterie.
Einem einem Haverboard alles wie du es brauchst.
Sogar mit oben dem dem Ding dran, um von der von von der.
Hier von der Stromleitung die Hochspannung abzugreifen das ist so ein geiles Teil. 1.872 Legoteile, ein Delorien mit Flügeltüren, alles.
Alles. Siehst du das?
Ich sehe das, aber ihr fragt mich halt irgendwie, warum äh betonst du das mit dem 1 April? Also war das jetzt sozusagen eine besondere.
Der Verkaufsstart. Ich war ich hatte den kurzen, ich es gab ein kurzes Zeitfenster, in dem er das Ding bestellen konnte und ich habe eine bekommen.
Die hast du auch schon.
Die ist heute gekommen, ja.
Zusammengebaut.
Nee, hatte ich noch keine Zeit für. Aber dann habe ich mir überlegt, mache ich denn jetzt baue ich die zusammen und dann lasse ich die eingepackt. Ne?
Ja weil ja äh das ist jetzt ein äh ist er quasi ein Investment jetzt. Das ist ja eine Wertanlage. Und äh wenn man die verpackt lässt äh kann man.
Hättest du zwei kaufen müssen.
Habe ich dann auch.
Ja, wobei ich meine, wenn sie funktioniert, kannst du ja zusammenbauen, dann kannst du ja jederzeit wieder zurück zum 1. April und noch mehr welche.
Neuer Hunde.
Nee, aber ich habe tatsächlich äh äh frei bestellt. Ähm also tatsächlich ich gehe eher davon aus, dass ich die Zweite irgendwann mal.
Als als als zu einem Geburtstag ein würdige ähm Leute verschenke oder,
die jetzt wirklich äh so durch die Decke geht preislich. Hm dann finanziere ich damit einfach meine erste.
Du musst einfach nur lang genug durchhalten, dann dann ist das Ding noch noch sehr viel mehr wert.
Was allerdings fehlt, ist der ähm Almanach. Den sehe ich da jetzt noch nicht.
Aber du hast alles, das ist so geil und fasziniert so Philippas, guckst du.
Nein nein.
Muss man schon irgendwie in den 80ern dann noch halbwegs jung gewesen sein.
Aber das.
Um mir ein Lego-Stück zu kaufen und dann ernsthaft denke so boah ey, ich kaufe zwei. Das äh äh kann mich auch so ein bisschen schäbig vor.
Aber äh ich bin guter Dinge, dass das äh ein dass das zwei besser sind als eine. Ich habe ja quasi jetzt zwei.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein besseres Investment als Bitcoin.
Und also ja wobei zwei Bitcoin,
weil so wenn sagen wir mal so, wenn das Ding auch nochmal jetzt von hundert,
Euro sich auf auf Bitcoin Kursniveau begibt, würde ich mich jetzt auch nicht beschweren.
Ist das geil, ey.
Aber kein albernacht, das stimmt.
Einmal nach ja,
Es gibt sogar, ich habe bei Golem den den Dingens gelesen, es gibt sogar drei war Aufbauvarianten, weil es in den drei Filmen ganz kleine Modifikationen an dem Delorean gibt.
Und an entsprechender Stelle in der Aufbauanleitung wirst dann eben gefragt so na ja welchen möchtest du denn bauen,
freue ich mich. Mal gucken, wann ich Zeit habe, dir aufzubauen. Ähm und ich denke mir mal, die andere, mal gucken, entweder verkaufe ich die auf eBay oder mit meinen weniger kostet oder Geil. Ja, finde ich super. Da,
ich verschenke die zu Geburtstag. Wobei es ungünstig einige meiner Freundinnen und Freunde hören diesen Podcast.
Ähm ja okay. War vielleicht jetzt nicht so klug.
Dann bleib einfach bei Wertanlage. Das eine ist zum Angeben, das andere ist zum Reichwerden.
Beides nicht verkehrt, ne? Wenn man also der äh wir haben ja letzte ähm Sendung hier gesprochen von der ukrainischen Familie, die der Tobi untergebracht hat.
Soll ich jetzt in den Statuscode erstmal erklären oder ähm müsste erstmal das.
Ja genau, aber damit ich wollte das schon mal anteasern, wie die Leute sich denn dranbleiben.
Das ist auch okay. Ja,
Also können wir das jetzt hier sozusagen einfach noch mit reinschieben. Ist auch äh relativ unaufregend. Der Status äh vier zwo äh sechs. Heißt Upgrade required.
Das kennen wir ja alle dieses Gefühl. Ne? Und äh Upgrade Required ist relativ einfach. Das ist äh schlicht und ergreifend,
dass Nachrüsten äh der Versionskontrolle, also nicht jetzt wie geht äh Datei äh Versionskontrolle, sondern einfach was so Diversionierung von HTTP selber betrifft,
Wenn man halt irgendwohin äh connectet und sagt, so hallo, ich bin's, ich spreche HTTP eins Punkt eins und aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
äh will dieser Webserver nicht mehr mit diesem Oldschool HTTP antworten, sondern sagt einfach so,
eins Punkt eins not spoken hier. Du musst,
Hier bitte, das ist die Version mit von der ich möchte, dass du mit mir äh ähm so redest.
Gut, Tim.
Maulschelle.
Wichtig, der demnächst drauf hinweisen kann, wie ich möchte, wie du mit mir sprichst.
Ja, Upgrade-Require hat.
Auch nicht schlecht. Alter, wir zwo sechs, Alter.
In der letzten Sendung. Wann haben wir die aufgenommen vor etwas über einer Woche oder vor einer Woche? Weiß gar nicht genau.
1. April war das. Wollteste ja nicht, dass äh ich das äh petze, aber so war's.
Am 1. April. So lang ist das schon her.
Ja, du hast gesagt, ich äh jetzt habe ich's gesagt und ähm.
Über eine Woche her. Das genau. Äh guck mal, wie lange ich an dem Tag wach war, da habe ich diese Maschine bestellt.
Richtig viel los.
Da hatte ich ähm,
Ja von der ukrainischen Familie erzählt die der Tobi in seiner Wohnung unterbringt, die,
Äh ja, haben.
Viele Leute gemacht. Ich habe außerdem übrigens noch der wie das so ist, ne? Dann äh nee, ich erzähle erst die die Spenden,
Ja, also insgesamt sind bis heute Mittag,
12. April 5.859 Euro eingegangen.
Aha, okay.
Das ist mehr als ein halbes Jahr Miete,
und macht natürlich jetzt irgendwie keinen Sinn, dass so lang aufzubewahren das Geld in der Erwartung, dass man es so lange braucht. Ähm ich hatte in den Shownotes und es werden auch alle,
gelesen haben, denn nur dort gab es ja den Link zu Tobis Paypal-Account. Äh hatte ich geschrieben, sollte da mehr zusammenkommen,
dann suchen wir uns einen Weg äh also er hatte geschrieben
Falls mehr Geld zusammenkommt als für die Miete benötigt wird, zum Beispiel weil der verfluchte
Krieg plötzlich endet aufgrund einer hervorragenden Integration die Wohnung nicht mehr benötigt wird oder weil staatliche Hilfen greifen, geht der Überschuss an
Eine Organisation in der Geflüchtetenhilfe, auch das wird Ihnen jetzt berichten. Jetzt hatten wir auf einmal also diesen
relativ großen Haufen Geld da liegen und denke nicht, dass wir jetzt auf sechs Monate planen müssen, weil wenn es so lange dauert, dann können wir ähm,
Auch einfach das nochmal ansprechen, insofern hätten wir uns jetzt schlecht gefühlt, dieses,
halt ein halbes Jahr aufzubewahren ähm.
Und es gibt ja genug Menschen, die jetzt Geld brauchen. Also habe ich mich im Berliner,
Aktivistinnen und Bekanntenkreis umgehört und da hat sich dann eine Gruppe von Freundinnen bei mir gemeldet, beziehungsweise ich mit dem Kontakt aufgenommen, die bereits seit einem Jahr Geflüchtete,
aus äh Russland äh also Dissidentinnen aus Russland unterbringen äh mit Kindern auf dem Weg äh zum Asylantrag in Deutschland.
Und dieser Asylantrag wird auch bald gestellt werden können. Bis dahin ist noch äh zwei Monatsmieten zu zahlen, dann wird man mal sehen, was dabei rumkommt und ähm,
da jetzt grade alle für die ukrainischen vor Putin geflohenen Menschen flüchten und in diesem Fall die,
russische Politik,
die russische politische Dissidentin ähm von eben den Berliner Freundinnen und Freunden von mir unterstützt wird.
Gesagt, okay
dann gehen wir das mal dahin, weil die das jetzt schon seit sehr langer,
Ähm außerdem äh kommt Tobi so gut mit der Familie klar, dass er jetzt da wahrscheinlich bald dann spätestens im,
Juni auch,
eben ein WG-Zimmer beziehen wird, sodass da auch die Kosten sinken. Unterm Strich haben wir also jetzt für,
nächste Zeit erstmal von den fünftausendachthundert Euro dreitausendsiebenhundertfünfzig,
verplant. Damit werden insgesamt 9 Personen,
Die nächsten zwei, drei Monate ähm untergebracht sein ähm und,
Dann haben wir jetzt einen Rest aufbewahrt von, dass wir rechnen kann 250 Euro und 59 Cent, die wir,
uns wagen, zurückzuhalten und zwar für Nachzahlung Heizkosten. Äh die zweite Hälfte.
Äh also noch eine ein Teil der Junite für die Künstlerinnenfamilie mit Kindern
und wenn die Familien einmal die ukrainische einmal die Dissidentinnenfamilie umziehen muss, kommen ja auch noch mal Kosten auf uns zu, sodass wir jetzt also für,
so diesen Betrag fühlte ich mich jetzt erstmal ganz wohl noch zurückzuhalten für etwaige Mehrkosten.
Und da kommt auch tatsächlich immer Bedarf äh auf uns zu, zum Beispiel hat jetzt die Mutter, brauchte einen Computer für Remote-Unterricht.
Also äh habe ich ein organisiert. Eins Akpad funktionierte X eins Carbon. Ich meine gut ähm zur Verarbeitungsqualität brauche ich natürlich als MacBook.
Nutzer nix zu sagen, aber ähm gut äh das Ding fertiggemacht mit Windows und allem, also mit spitzen Fingern. Fertigen Computer hingestellt, nächsten Tag hatte das Ding Lüfterschaden.
Also habe ich da jetzt einen zweiten Rechner von einer Freundin organisiert und ähm,
jetzt kann die Mutter auf jeden Fall remote,
Unterricht machen und,
krasse Geschichte, also irgendwie so heute Morgen eben schrieben, ja gut,
Shit, Computer geht nicht mehr an, also piept und Fan Error, ne und dann schickte sie irgendwie so ein Foto ausm Fenster so ausm Küchenfenster und ich dachte erstmal,
Was ist das für ein Foto, ne? Warum schickt er mir jetzt dieses Bild? Wollte dir das jemand anderem schicken oder so?
Sieht aus wie eine Rakete und ich habe irgendwie S überhaupt nicht gecheckt, was sie was auf dem Bild wie eine Rakete aussah da waren halt ähm Kondensstreifen, so einen Kondensstreifen am Himmel Und dazu der Text äh.
Die man ja auch tatsächlich wegen Corona eine Zeit lang nicht so gesehen hat und äh ja habe ich auch wieder gedacht, ey was eine.
Ein Scheiß ja insofern ähm ich glaube in beiden Fällen ist das,
Geld gut angelegt. Sollte jetzt,
eine von den Spenderinnen äh sagen, nee, möchte ich nicht, dass die andere Familie davon unterstützt wird. Ähm,
könnt ihr über den gleichen Link euer Geld auch zurückfordern. Haben übrigens auch einige gemacht. Die haben dann von Tobi Geld gefordert. Statt zu spenden,
Ich glaube, die die PayPal-Nutzerinnenführung war da nicht so äh optimal,
aber okay. Die Sache läuft also wie gesagt 3750 haben wir jetzt erstmal verplant 2000 halten wir in der Hand. Damit kann.
In dem einen Fall dann einfach mal noch oder in beiden Fällen, je nachdem nochmal einen Monat hinten drangehängt werden,
O2, je nachdem in welcher Wohnung das anfällt und äh ja.
Heizkosten und sonstige aus äh besondere Anforderungen. Dafür halten wir das mal zurück, aber auch mit dem Ziel,
ähm dass das bald loszuwerden, ja? Also wird jetzt wird alles diesem.
Zukommen. Ich bin ein bisschen überrascht gewesen, dass das so viel Geld war und möchte an dieser Stelle mal der Community danken. Ich hätte jetzt, also ich habe gedacht, so ja.
Wenn.
Das denke ich auch. Super Aktion, vielen Dank an alle, die sich hier engagieren.
Ja wirklich viel und
ganz besonderer Moment, dass dann auch so zu sehen, ähm das was ihr da so gemacht habt, hat mich enorm enorm gefreut. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Dann kommen wir mal zum Feedback. Ähm hatten wir glaube ich letztes Mal gar nicht und von daher
ein paar Sachen auf, ein Kommentar von Igor Feel mir ins Auge zu dieser ganzen Frage mit ähm Zensur und Nicht-Zensur RT äh will man jetzt sozusagen
Propagandasender hier äh verbieten und ähm,
Diskussion, die wir auch darüber geführt haben so mit diesen zwei Herzen in der Brust, dass man halt auf der einen Seite natürlich für eine offene Kommunikations äh für offene Kommunikationswege
eintritt, aber auf der anderen Seite auch einfach diese unmittelbare Problematik äh und Bedrohungen sieht und darauf auch reagieren möchte,
Äh Igor schreibt, hallo Leute zum Thema Zensur soll man verbieten dürfen oder nicht,
soll jeder einfache, jeden Schwachsinn erzählen dürfen, dazu,
Bildschirm heilte und vieles mehr. Und auch Wasser, dass Leute sich vor den Bildschirm stellen sollten mit Energie und heilender Wirkung aufladen konnte. Kein Witz. Das haben Millionen Leute geguckt und Wasser hingestellt. Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen über den.
Haben die Amis aber auch gemacht, ne.
Ähm im staatlichen Fernsehen.
Das habt ihr, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Na ja das also klar ne, das Problem haben wir natürlich so in diesem Privatfernsehen auch, ne?
Äh voller Absicht einen Krankenspinner dazu benutzt, um Massen zu manipulieren. Es gibt viele Menschen, die mit Inhalten, die über die Kanäle wie äh Tee verbreitet werden, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht umgehen können. Ähm Igor Walter, die Obersten haben mit,
Heute sehen wir, dass die gleichen Leute, die damals ein Glas Wasser vor der TV-Kiste gestellt haben, heute daran glauben, dass Putin ein Botschafter des Friedens ist und hier erstürmen sie das Bundestagsgebäude.
Auch in einer Demokratie muss man solche klar manipulativen Inhalte, die dann in Störung des öffentlichen Friedens ausarten oder gar Gewalt
oder beschränken können, dass dabei in Bildung und Aufklärung das Erlernen des kritischen Denkens massiv investiert werden muss, ist selbstverständlich.
Schickt er auch noch gleich einen Link zum Video dieser Sendung, wo die Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen über den Bildschirm geheilt werden sollen, ja. Möge die Macht mit uns sein. Gut,
Ja also können da gar nichts weiter zu zu sagen. Das ist halt.
Eine der Sichtweisen, die man hier haben kann. Dann äh haben wir uns ja ähm
entzückt geäußert über diese äh
diese Standard, die offensichtlich
stellt sich raus, ähm Mario und Sebastian haben da Informationen geliefert. Ähm,
dass es sich hierbei um so eine spezielle ähm Aktivistengruppe im Militärhandel, die äh sozusagen damit ihre LG,
T äh Zugehörigkeit zeigt und äh quasi da ein aufmacht für Soldaten, die halt irgendwie schwul sind und ähm
damit irgendwie offen umgehen wollen und das ist quasi so ein Symbol dieser äh Gruppe. Da steckt also auch noch ein konkreter Aktivismus. Ähm,
dahinter die Links dazu äh haben wir auch noch in die äh gepackt.
Das heißt, die Ukraine hat eine Armee, die ähm moderner ist als die Fußballbundesliga.
Äh mit Sicherheit.
Und glaube ich so ungefähr jede andere Armee. Also mir ich weiß gar nicht ähm.
Also Armeen sind jetzt generell nicht so dafür bekannt, besonders äh homofil äh zu sein und irgendwie besonders vogue unterwegs zu sein, also von daher ähm.
Okay. Ja, aber das ist also wenn dann Einhorn-Standarte oder? Das ist für.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall äh das richtige Symbol an der Stelle. Kann ich nur unterstützen so für so für so progressive Bewegung steht das.
Überall weltweit.
Ein Kommentar zum digitalen Unterricht. Ich hatte ja hier darüber äh gewitzelt, dass die ukrainischen ähm,
Kinder und auch die ukrainischen Politikerinnen, Bildungsministerin äh das ablehnen, jetzt äh,
sich ihr Leben im vom deutschen Bildungssystem ruinieren zu lassen, ja. Ich habe schließlich genug mitgemacht
Ähm dazu kommentierte Herbert. Am deutschen Schulsystem herumzunörgeln ist für die kabarettische Einlage recht ertragreich, da es eine tiefhängende Frucht,
Die Ukrainerinnen nutzen für ihre Telebeschulung Weiber für den Datentransfer und Zoom für die Unterrichtsstunde.
Kleiner Einschub kann ich übrigens bestätigen. Genau das ist der Fall. Musste ja so einen Laptop herrichten.
Bei uns werden die Systeme ja da teilweise höhere Anforderungen in puncto Datenschutz und Transparenz gestellt und wenn man Teams benutzt, dann ist das Geschrei unter Umständen groß.
Nun äh Herbert, bei aller Liebe, glaube ich, ehrlich gesagt, nicht dass das,
der Grund ist, warum hier die, sage ich mal, das digitalisierte Schulsystem in Deutschland noch Zukunftsmusik ist. Ähm.
Folgen bemessen. Erstens haben wir den ganzen Einsturz ja bei der,
mit dem Beginn der Coronapandemie gesehen, dass so gut wie keine Schule auch nur im entferntesten in der Nähe von vorbereitet darauf war, überhaupt einen Remote-Unterricht zu machen.
Aber da in diesen Zeiten Geschichten gehört, wo Lehrerinnen,
sich geweigert haben und auch weigern konnten offenbar, das hat das wurde geduldet ähm Remote-Unterricht zu machen, weil sie keinen Computer haben.
Ja. Und was weiß ich, der Arbeitsrechner vom äh von der Partnerin oder vom Partner,
den könnten sie nicht nutzen, weil der der Partnerin oder Partner will das nicht, weil sie Angst haben, dass die Schüler dann da irgendwie Viren draufmachen.
So. Also wenn wenn ich meine, wenn wenn,
eine Lehrkraft, eine derartige Geschichte erzählen kann, ja und das auch nur in der Nähe von akzeptiert wird und dann liegt das halt nicht an an Microsoft Teams oder an Zoom oder an,
Weiber, was irgendein Messenger ist, ja? Das liegt einfach daran, dass das dass es hier in Deutschland nicht Teil der Bildungspolitik ist.
Nie gewesen ist,
ja? Und digitaler Unterricht würde ja zum Beispiel auch mal damit weitergehen, dass du so was wie Medienkompetenz oder solche Themen einfach mal fest in gleichbleibender Qualität in einem.
Nicht, wir hatten ja Steine vor, sicherlich schon länger her. Steine ja hier, der dann noch in seiner Freizeit sagt, okay komm ich bringe den äh Schülerinnen ein bisschen was mit Digital bei. Unterrichtsangebot verankert hast und,
Das ist einfach in Deutschland nicht verankert. Das hat glaube ich weniger mit den mit den hohen Anforderungen der Deutschen an digitale Technologien zu tun. Da muss ich glaube ich tatsächlich widersprechen.
Und und die Schuld liegt jetzt aber auch nicht unbedingt nur bei den Lehrern, weil von denen.
Nein, richtig.
Zu viel erwartet äh wird so das Problem haben, dass äh was weiß ich
als auch noch einen Fernunterricht machen, alles in derselben Zeit, in der die sowieso schon total
überfordert sind natürlich auch mit ihrer eigenen persönlichen Situation grad so wie so ein Corona äh vergisst man ja auch mal schnell, dass da die Lehrer davon auch selber betroffen sind, ne. Also.
Corona ist jetzt eine Sache.
Ja klar, aber auch auch das Problem stellt sich da, ne,
Na ja, da sind wir uns einig. Auf jeden Fall ist das äh alles nicht.
Ja also,
sondern auch um die leeren Inhalte, Lehrinhalte. Ja, es ist einfach nicht so, dass das in Deutschland ein einheitlich,
im Lehrplan, in allen Bundesländern verankert ist.
Konkurrenzfähiges, zukunftsgerichtetes Digitalangebot gibt und zwar, ne, einfach,
den Kindern vermitteln, in was für einer Welt sie leben werden, mit welchen Geräten sie dort klarkommen müssen und mit welchen sozialen Netzwerken sie da irgendwie,
sich gegenseitig mobben können. Ja, das wird denen ja nicht wird hier alles nicht erklärt.
Und da muss man sich eben nicht wohnen, also und die Konsequenz davon ist, es gibt dann eben einige,
wenige, die diese Technologien in ihrer Freizeit durch entsprechende Förderung von ihren Eltern,
äh sich näherbringen, beherrschen, lernen und nachher entsprechende berufliche Aussichten und auch gesellschaftliche Gestaltungsaussichten haben und die anderen hängen halt bei,
fest oder was die machen. Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist nicht gut. So, Cyber Water, der Cyber Wars in vollem Gange.
Ist er jetzt endlich? Letzte Mal hast du dich ja noch beklagt, dass da irgendwie nix richtiges passiert.
Nee, nee, nee, ich Moment, ich habe ich habe klar gesagt, dass die dass die äh nicht militärischen Aktionen in dem Bereich nicht geeignet sind, äh die Kriegs,
Bereitschaft oder die Kriegswillen und Funktionsfähigkeit der von Putins Armeen zu beeinträchtigen und ich denke mit dieser These bin ich auch nach wie vor ganz gut gefahren,
Ähm auch wenn mich kürzlich jemand fragt, ich wusste erst gar nicht, was der von mir will. Ob ich an der Front bin.
Ob du an der Front bist.
Der Hintergrund der Frage war wahrscheinlich, ob ich halt irgendwie am Hecken bin, die Ukraine und ich einfach nur gesagt, ich bin grundsätzlich nicht an der Front. Ich bin immer nur im Untergrund. also äh sie fragte also,
nickte er wissend und zog von dannen. Ähm die Situation, also.
Damit hätte ich einfach drauf geantwortet, äh ich bin nicht befugt dir zu äh Auskunft.
Müsste ich dich leider hacken. Wenn ich ich könnte dir sagen, aber dann müsste ich dich hacken. Also die äh was,
ist jetzt schon zu Beginn gab und was jetzt auch weitergegangen sind äh ist sind eben äh einige Angriffe,
gegen die Ukraine von Russland ausgehen einmal eine,
Schadsoftware, die sich gegen Industrial Control Systems richtet, also äh in diesem Fall spezifisch auf eine.
Energieversorgungs, auf einen Energieversorgungsunternehmen und es gab schon mal einen Angriff äh auf die Ukraine, auf die Energieversorgung oder auch wo die auch einen längeren Ausfall hat. Ich glaube, zwanzig 16
Und das Ding wurde jetzt hier von ich weiß immer nicht, wie man die hier ausspricht.
Ihr seht, schätze ich mal. Äh die haben.
Jetzt diesen zwei entdeckt, also wieder eine eine Attacke mit Viperware, die sich eben gegen,
spezifisch darauf abzielt so eine,
Elektrizitätsverteilungsstationen dann eben zu stören und gleichzeitig ähm ein Linux, das Linux und solaris Netzwerk kaputtzumachen,
Also ziemlich spezifisch auf eine solche ähm Anlage ausgerichtete Schadsoftware.
Und ähm ein Viper, also im Prinzip zwei, ne, die ähm einen sehr fortgeschrittenen Eindruck machen und die ähm.
Atribuieren sie auf die Gruppe APT achtundzwanzig, die advanced Frates werden ja durchnummeriert oder haben,
besondere Namen, äh diesen Angriff, äh wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, atributieren sie auf Sandwarm, die Unit,
äh sieben vierundvierzig fünfundfünfzig, also dem GRU und äh.
Gehen also davon aus, dass die hier diesen Angriff auf die,
Ukraine durchgeführt haben und zwar habe ich mich gerade vertan, denn sie haben den ersten Angriff auf das auf die ukrainische Stromversorgung zwanzig15 gemacht. 2017 noch mal welche,
ähm angeblich wird dieser Gruppe auch zugeordnet in zwanzig,
17 Angriff auf die französische Präsidentschaftswahl sowie ein Angriff auf die Eröffnungs,
Zeremonie der Winterolympiade zwanzig achtzehn. Also den, die sind unterwegs und versuchen kritische Infrastrukturen in der Ukraine zu stören, dass ähm,
offenbar nicht in in nennenswertem Ausmaße gelungen, weil sie entdeckt wurden. Dann.
Hat Microsoft Research,
die Gruppe auch bekannt unter den Namen so äh Stronzium und APT achtundzwanzig, ja, APT ist ja gerne auch mal nummeriert ähm,
die haben eine,
ja so eine Wurmkampagne liest sich das eigentlich so, wo sie also es ist eher in Richtung Spionage ging,
ähm und die haben dann die Domains unter Kontrolle genommen, wo die hinfunken, um diesen um diese ähm commanden control,
ähm Kommunikation eben umzuleiten.
Mir,
Leuten zu tun, dass sie dann da offenbar Zink holen.
Kann es sein, dass das irgendein Mechanismus in Windows ist, den Sie da aktivieren.
Ich jetzt auch überlegt, ja,
dass sie's.
Ja, das.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass die sagen, mhm.
Dass sie in deine Tabellen und aufm untersten Level, also ich meine, wenn du's auf dem Host machen willst und wenn du jetzt sagst, okay alle.
Ausnahmslos alle Windows Rechner, die sich dahin verbinden wollen,
muss sich umlenken,
Ja? Es könnte ja sein, dass sie's über IP-Adressen machen.
Also ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich habe also es wird sicherlich ähm relativ einfach herauszufinden sein, ich hab's in dieser Recherche jetzt einfach nur mal zur Kenntnis genommen.
Dass sie's getan haben, ne? Also wenn sie nur über DNS-Server gehen würden, wären sie auf jeden Fall nicht bei allen. Also tja.
Immerhin haben sie was gemacht und offensichtlich hat's funktioniert.
Gemacht,
Ja und,
wenn ich versuche mich da so ein bisschen mit auseinanderzusetzen mit diesen.
Kriegsstrategien, ja, da gibt's ja diesen Podcast äh Streitkräfte und Strategien. Der hatte mir einen Freund vor kurzem empfohlen ähm,
also zu Beginn der,
äh das scheint ja jetzt nicht ganz nach Plan zu laufen,
Putin und insofern kann das und die.
Wir hatten hier schon berichtet, dass die Renzel Weare von Conti oder das Conti ja alles Mögliche geleakt wurde. Da wird jetzt die,
Conti rentsomware irgendwie.
Genutzt mit Modifikationen, um russische Unternehmen zu hacken, was ich auch natürlich auch ganz gut finde, ja, äh also von einer vom Heck Value halt zu sagen, alles klar, nehmen wir die.
Das FBI hat außerdem noch gesagt, dass sie ein Bordnetz eines russischen Geheimdienstes lahmgelegt hätten.
Und ähm tja die Ukraine arbeitet ja immer ein bisschen hemdsärmeliger, möchte man sagen. Die schleppen die,
Panzer mit Traktoren weg und nutzen jetzt die geplünderten Apple Produkte, weil äh dann nutzen sie das, äh wo ist Feature, ja also wo dann irgendwelchen Leuten.
Wo eben nach den Raubzügen der russischen Armee dann die Wertsachen natürlich äh gerne mal mitgenommen werden und man die dann über ICloud tracken kann.
Ja das ist wirklich lustig, weil ja
es wird ja gerade alles mitgenommen bei ihren Rückzügen, haben ja Kühlschränke einge,
und so weiter, also es äh herrscht offensichtlich in ihren äh Heimatorten größte Not und äh nahezu jedes Item in diesen Wohnungen ist in irgendeiner Form,
äh es wert mitgenommen zu werden und natürlich sind dann solche High-Tech,
wie Apods äh ganz weit vorne. Nur dass die eben mittlerweile auch die AirPods, aber auf jeden Fall natürlich so die Rechner.
Eben an diesem
Netzwerk teilnehmen und so quasi kleine Bluetooth-Beatins aussenden, die dann von anderen iPhones eingesammelt und an den eigentlichen
Besitzer dieser Geräte äh zurückgemeldet werden und so kann man halt dann schön sehen, wie die Soldaten sich eben durch äh Weißrussland bewegen und an neue Standorte gefahren werden.
Ja, nicht verkehrt. Viel Spaß mit den Airpods und da haben die hat die russische,
äh hatte Russland ohnehin ein bisschen Problem und zwar gab es ein Leak von Jandex Eats, äh was so ein Essenslieferservice ist.
Und da sind offenbar eine ganze Menge Lieferungen rausgefallen, die sich dann äh angeschaut hat und die haben unter anderem,
eine bislang unbekannte Person darüber identifiziert, die in Verbindung mit dem Giftanschlag auf Alexei Nawalny steht,
und auch weitere Gebäude des Geheimdienstes und des Militärs als solche bestätigen können.
Ich stelle mir das so vor, dass sie das gemacht haben, weil Leute,
über diese bekannte Leute, über diese Gebäude gewandert sind und da Essen hingestellt haben, ne und äh ja
da wenn man sich wirklich mit solchen Leaks auseinandersetzt, kann man da echt äh interessante Informationen draus gewinnen.
Ja, es gibt vor allem mittlerweile fast keine Datenbanken mehr, aus denen man nicht irgendwelche Informationen gewinnen kann. Und alles, was natürlich mit so Personen,
Uhrzeiten, Dienstleistungen zu tun hat,
da kann man richtig schön viel äh Dinge rauskämmen, vor allem wenn man sich dann eben mit anderen wieder kombiniert, ne, also die grad dieses Überprüfen von Adressen oder das Überprüfen von,
Leuten, die in irgendeiner Form im Zusammenhang stehen, über Telefonnummern et cetera PP geht da geben solche Sachen natürlich eine Menge her, ne. Wer hat uns äh verraten? Die Meter.
Also das sind jetzt, sage ich mal, die wahren Ausprägungen des Cyber Wars, ja, also,
äh Spionage und Sabotage, die beiden Dinge, die wir immer benennen, hier offenbar zum Glück äh gut abgewehrt
da gehört glaube ich eine eine große Portion Glück dazu, dass so etwas gelingt. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig muss ich auch sagen, gehört eine große Portion Glück dazu, dass so ein Angriff gelingt, insofern,
wie dem auch sei. So sieht's auf jeden Fall zur Zeit aus, währenddessen das Ganze Cyber-Wargeschrei der letzten,
ja, was uns bald 50 Tage kann natürlich nicht ohne Konsequenzen bleiben.
Im Koalitionsvertrag der Ampelkoalition steht ja sehr klar, Hackbacks lehnen wir als Mittel der Cyber-Abwehr grundsätzlich ab
Allerdings hat die CDU, ich glaube allen voran hier Friedrich Merz, ja schon vor einigen Wochen begonnen diese Welle zu reiten,
und äh auch Nancy Phaser äh drängt jetzt immer mehr darauf,
im Bereich der sogenannten Cybersicherheit mehr Kompetenzen beim Bund zu bündeln, was jetzt erstmal keine,
so schlechte Idee ist, ja, du möchtest ein vielleicht nicht unbedingt das äh diese Cyber-Gefahrenabwehr überwiegend Ländersache ist. Ich hatte dazu ja auch
in meiner Stellungnahme,
zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei mal diese Grafik der Cybersicherheitsarchitektur der Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
eingebaut und gesagt, so sie möge jemanden,
äh möge diese Grafik verstehen oder jemanden finden, der ihr die erklären kann, ja, aber ich kann's auch nicht.
Insofern jetzt so grundsätzlich bei dieser Gefahrenabwehr im IT-Sicherheitsbereich die Kompetenzen auf Bundesebene zu bündeln halte ich jetzt für keine so schlechte Idee, aber,
Jetzt geht es auch um Befugnisse der aktiven Cyber-Abwehr, also an diesen Cyber werden wir uns gewöhnen müssen.
Das äh wie gesagt Ampel sagt eigentlich relativ klar, ist nicht äh die Idee und sagte auch Manuel Höferlin von der FDP.
Statt unterkomplexe Forderungen aufzustellen, wäre es an der Zeit, dass das Parlament sich mit Experten aus dem Cyberraum
Verfassungsrechtlern und zuständigen Institutionen in einem Expertengremium verständigt, wie man Cybersicherheit und damit auch Cyber-Abwehr rechtssicher und schlagkräftig so aufstellt,
dass Sie sowohl in Friedens als auch als auch in Kriegszeiten,
allen Herausforderungen gewachsen ist. Und diesen Satz muss ich einfach mal sagen, dass genau das ist genau das Richtige, ja, die die Situation ist ja.
Wir sitzen im Glashaus und überlegen uns jetzt mal ein paar fette Steine zu kaufen und das geht halt schief. Ja und nur dadurch, dass du deine aktiven Möglichkeiten ausbaust,
heißt es nicht, dass deine Verteidigungsmöglichkeiten besser werden und wer meint mit einem Schwert in den Kampf ziehen zu müssen, sollte eben auch ein Schild mitbringen,
in der Erwartung, dass auf der anderen Seite auch ein Schwert auf dich wartet und,
Bei dem Zustand, den ich in diesem Bereich nun mal wirklich leider sehe, halte ich es für eine au äußerst schlechte Idee,
nicht,
alles in die Absicherung zu zu investieren, weil das ist ja das, was man also es wird auch immer dieser Begriff des Hackbacks suggeriert ja.
Dass durch den Gegenschlag eine Minderung stattfände
des eigenen Schadens oder des eigenen Leids. Und das ist der das ist der große große Unsinn, den man hier sieht
ja? Deswegen habe ich auch gerade so ein bisschen über dieses Cyber Walk Kapitel gesprochen, über die über diese Meldungen, weil was da passiert ist, ist,
erkannt und abgewehrt. Das sind die,
Das sind die Erfolgsgeschichten. Nicht boah ey, Hack und Backe, jetzt haben wir zurückgehackt, ne? Das ist alles Quatsch. Das ist das ist führt ja zu nichts. Ähm wir müssen ja,
wie Manuel Hüfferdin das.
Und jetzt haben wir natürlich die Situation, dass die CDU,
treibt dann jetzt die Innenministerin vor sich her, die Ampel sagt, halt man nichts von. Kannst du dir vorstellen, in welche Richtung das laufen soll? Übrigens, noch ein bisschen,
Hintergrund,
unterdroht äh Anarchie. Ja? Äh weil eben dann die Frage nach der Legitimation eines Einsatzes offen ist,
ebenso wie die Definition der Schwelle, ab der man eben eine Reaktion.
Erfolgen lässt. Und hier hat er in dieser Formulierung verbirgt sich ja auch ganz klar das, worauf das hinlaufen soll,
Es geht um die Militarisierung und die militärische Nutzung von solchen Cyberwaffen. Das heißt, was hier eigentlich gerade als Diskussion stattfindet,
von den Befugnissen auf der Befugnissebene, das. In der Talkshow siehst du, oh, oh, oh, der Russe hakt,
Wir müssen uns wehren können.
Ab heute wird zurückgehakt.
Heute wird zurückgehakt und so weiter und so fort. Das ist das,
Das ist das, was wir hören und sitzen sie alle brav und sagen, um den Angriff zu stoppen, um den zu verhindern, um den zurückzuverfolgen. Das ist das, was diskutiert wird,
was in den Befugnissen steht ist, oh oh, der Russe-Hack müssen wir auch können. Niemand, der irgendwie halbwegs sich mit diesem Thema auseinandergesetzt hat,
vertritt die Ansicht, dass irgendwie ein ein laufender Cyberangriff
ne? Da sitzen die dann im im Krisenraum und sehen so eine Rakete über den Globus fliegen, ne. Das ist Cyber Rakete und dann kommt der Raketenschild und der hackt,
und schießt sie dann ab und dann sagen die boah Alter ey,
Cyberangriff abgewehrt. Jetzt kommt es schon der nächste, da müssen wir auch wieder eine Hakbar-Rakete. So stellen die sich das ja vor, das ist absoluter Unsinn.
Absoluter Unsinn. So und aber so sitzen die da.
Rakete ist schön.
Ja, ist doch so. Und dann das ist nicht das, was was die da auf der Befugnissebene.
Sagen sie im Prinzip alles klar, wir brauchen genauso wie wir Regeln dafür haben, wann wir,
ähm irgendetwas kaputt machen dürfen mit Raketen,
Da haben wir Regeln für brauchen wir Regeln, dafür waren wir irgendwas hacken dürfen. Und dann nochmal der Hinweis, wenn du,
ernsthaft und das habe ich sieht man ja jetzt auch hier an dem an den Dingen, ist jetzt auch keine besondere Weisheit, wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt.
Es erfordert enorme Vorbereitungen
und enorme Spionage über Jahre bist du in der Lage bist äh ein Plan überhaupt zu haben, wie du irgendeine Infrastruktur angreifen kannst
und die stellen sich das irgendwie so vor. Wir haben eine wir witzeln da ja seit Jahren drüber, dass dann irgendwo morgens der.
Feldwebel reinkommt und sagt so Leute, heute hacken wir dat dat und das das funktioniert so nicht.
Also wirklich schade und ach so und natürlich in in diesem Zusammenhang wird natürlich werden immer diese 100 Milliarden Euro äh die die Bundeswehr ja jetzt verplanen kann.
Angesprochen, kannst du dir ja vorstellen, äh da da kannst du dir ja schon vorstellen, wie viele Cyber-Experten,
da
Ich glaube nicht, dass er viel Geld übrig bleiben wird.
Toll Collect da machen wir jetzt da machen wir nochmal Andi Scheuer, hat der Andi Scheuer es jemals geschafft 100 Milliarden zu verbrennen.
Andi Scheuer, das sind.
Mensch wenn du dir überlegst, wenn da jetzt die Cyber-Experten reinkommen und äh und irgendwie Bundeswehrbudgets äh abgreifen. Schneller hast du dieses Land nicht ruiniert. Das kriegt Andy Scheuern, die so nicht hin.
Noch nicht so sicher, dass bei den 100 Milliarden viel für Cyber übrig bleiben wird. Das äh glaube der Kernbedarf ist äh.
Erstmal neue Socken.
Ja erstmal neue also ich weiß nicht, habe so die Zahl gehört, dass allein um irgendwie die Bundeswehr
auf die von der NATO geforderten ähm Lagerbestände von Munition zu bringen, brauchst du schon mal 20 Milliarden.
Da hast du noch kein nix nix Neues erworben. Aber egal. Werden wir sehen.
Ähm ja ich also ich ich habe große Sorge, weil also,
Wenn die jetzt ernsthaft hier so einen Off-Hak machen, ne, also abgesehen davon, dass der dir sowieso totaler Unsinn ist, ne, weil es keinen realistisches Szenario abbildet. Aber die Leute,
Ich meine, ich kenne ja meine Cyber-Pappenheimer. Ja? Und.
Kein seriöser Mensch in der in der deutschen IT-Security ähm wird sich da ernsthaft hinstellen und sagen, wir wir können da euch was irgendwie klären, ja?
Gleichzeitig kannst du dir vorstellen oder kann ich nur mir schon ausmalen, wer da jetzt alle Schlange steht. Es gibt ja Leute, die singen dieses Lied ja seit zehn, 20 Jahren.
Die warten jetzt nur auf den Moment, dass sie endlich mit ihrem Hackback äh geschwätzt da jetzt irgendwie an die dicken Budgets kommen.
Und das ist äh da da wird,
Das ist wirklich ein bisschen zum Heulen.
Ne, ist es.
Apropos äh Blockchain-Zeugnisse, ne, verspäten sich.
Was? Wirklich, aber damit war doch nicht zu rechnen.
Nee, vor allem weil ja die,
Werden wir gemeint zu Herbert, aber weil das ja eigentlich alles nur.
Und zwar haben sie jetzt äh ein Jahr später als geplant wird es dann die ersten digitalen Schulzeugnisse in Rheinland-Pfalz geben und zwar für das Schuljahr zwanzig zwanzig zweiundzwanzig dreiundzwanzig.
Und der Grund ist Schwachstellen im Sicherheitssystem der Bundesdruckerei.
Ja und das ist das, was Flöpke und Little Wittmann irgendwie da kurz mal angeklickt haben, wo sie sagten so, Leute, kann ich euer Ernst sein? Ja und es ist,
Wie wie oft haben wir hier über diese blöden, digitalen Zeugnisse gesprochen Tim? Was für ein Quatsch! Tim Blockchain, du kannst dich aufregen.
Ja dazu ist ja eigentlich alles schon äh äh gesagt. Also das ist einfach keinerlei Notwendigkeit gibt für diese Blockchains, außer
dass äh die Unternehmen in dem Fall halt die Bundesdruckerei,
das ist ungefähr so als gäb's eine Brokkoliförderung und alle Bäcker müssen halt jetzt irgendwie Brokkolitorte machen,
keine haben wollte, aber das das Geld ist,
das keiner brauchen, keiner will, ist eine ganz andere Frage, ne.
Ich stelle mir gerade so vor. Ja, guck mal hier mit einem super Himbeersorbet. Ja, kann man das nicht auch mit Brokkoli machen? Ja, kann man, aber es schmeckt halt nicht.
Ja, aber hier das Steak, das kann jetzt nicht ja kann man. Aber.
Ein Steak mit Brokkoli, da da gehe ich ja jetzt mit so, ne? Aber in meinem Käsekuchen will ich einfach keinen Brokkoli drin haben.
Hier meine wunderschöne äh wunderschöne, ach ja, aber genau, das kann man jetzt nicht auch mit Brokkoli machen. Ja, kann man. Aber es ist halt einfach Kacke.
Ja wir wir brauchen keine Brokkoli-Käsekuchen und wir brauchen auch keine Blockchain-Zeugnisse. Ist einfach Unsinn. Aber es ist ja Windmöhlen.
Ja, okay, also das verspätet sich ähm.
Überraschenderweise.
Völlig überraschend, aber äh weißt du? Scheißzeugnis signieren, aber brauchst eine Hackback
So, dann das war glaube ich schon zur letzten Sendung fast fertig. Da hat er auch schon ich glaube, da ist noch irgendwie in die Shownotes gelandet und eine
sehr aufmerksame Hörerin.
Er hat festgestellt, dass das Kapitel fehlte. Der Text zum DMA steht. Also wir erinnern uns Digital Services Act und Digital Markets Act. Da habe ich eine sehr schönen sehr schönen,
sehr schöne Eselsbrücke gelesen. Der DSA für Services betrifft das, was die Plattform hosten.
Also die Services, die Sie anbieten.
Der DMA Markets betrifft das, was die Plattform tun, also ihre Markt den Markt, den sie da bespielen, ja oder den sie auch geschaffen haben in,
in ihrer Welt, aus die sie sich die sie sind. Ne und jetzt wurde halt der DMA-Text der Digital Markets äh Act Text abgestimmt.
Und er ist das Zusammenfügen von Daten aus unterschiedlichen Fällen sollen nicht mehr erlaubt sein.
Browser, Sprachassistenten und Suchmaschine sollen frei wählbar sein. Auch das also zum Beispiel so große Themen, ne, vor 20 Jahren gewesen. Microsoft hat hier, glaube ich, eine der größten,
äh Strafen der Geschichte äh bekommen, weil sie den Microsoft Internetexplorer mitgeliefert haben. Seitdem haben sich Plattformen etwas,
etwas vergrößert? Ähm es soll FIRT Party App Stores geben.
Und die Messenger-Interoperität soll auch kommen. Zu diesen Themen würde ich dann gerne nochmal,
LNP 24 digitalisierungsfehler,
empfehlen, die,
eben Interoperabilitätszwang besteht ähm
zumindest für die Messenger haben wir da eher nicht,
werden für die,
ja für die für die Markteinstiegshürden, denen ein neuer Messenger sich ausgesetzt sieht oder eben nicht ausgesetzt sieht.
Dann haben wir noch eine wunderbare Nachricht Tim Corona Warnapp Hotline ist die ganze Zeit belegt.
Ja.
Hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass Leute sich noch offiziell versuchen, den genesenen Status zu holen, ehrlich gesagt. Die Zahlen sinken doch, obwohl irgendwie inzwischen die Leute zum dritten Mal durchseucht werden.
Na, es,
sondern wenn du quasi nachträglich da äh die Warnung anstoßen möchte,
jetzt nicht, warum die Leute primär bei,
dass das Design so Rollout mit irgendwie, wenn ein Test stattfindet, das halt quasi schon so Zeitpunkt der Probenentnahme,
CBR QR Codes von vornherein gleich so an der richtigen Stelle den Leuten vorliegen, damit sie dann eben das entsprechend auch in ihrer App tracken können. Von daher
ist natürlich klar, dass der Druck auf diese Hotline steigt mit diesen extrem hohen Infektionszahlen.
Da jetzt keine konkreten Zahlen, wie das jetzt äh gelaufen ist, aber offensichtlich ist auch die recht üppig finanzierte Hotline da an ihre Grenzen gekommen.
00tausend im Monat, glaube ich, ne.
Geld meinst du jetzt? Ähm.
Kann sein, weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau, Größenordnungsmäßig, ja. Kriegst du halt schon ein paar Mitarbeiter äh mitfinanziert, aber eben jetzt auch nicht so viele, dass es ähm für.
Infektion haben wir pro Tag derzeit.
Irgendwo wieder runter. Ich weiß es noch nicht mal mehr. Also ich denke ehrlich gesagt, dass wir könnte man mal so einen Abstand mit Abstand betrachten,
Es gibt ein kleines, einen kleinen Fensterbereich des Infektionsgeschehens, bei dem Contact Tracing sinnvoll ist.
Und es gibt einen kleinen es gibt einen relativ großen Fensterbereich des Infektionsgeschehens, wo das Contact-Tacing,
nicht mehr sinnvoll ist. Wenn ich jetzt hier mal meine Corona-Warn-App aufmache.
Dir garantieren, dass die rot ist und das ist die mehr oder weniger mit einem Tag Unterbrechung seit irgendwie Ende Mitte, Ende November, ne. Jetzt April, gerade habe ich zwei rote Warnungen,
und das bezieht sich auf die letzten 14 Tage, ne? Das Ding ist seit irgendwie Ende November seit Mitte Ende November ist es bei mir einmal,
Nee, zweimal war's grün, ja? Das eine Mal war, da hatte irgendwie ein paar Tage das Update nicht funktioniert, da hatte ich morgens grün, da habe ich gesagt, super,
Habe ich am nächsten habe ich irgendwie am,
nächsten Tag waren die wieder direkt wieder,
aber sonst kann ich kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass diese Corona-Wahn mal nicht rot war als Bewohner von Berlin.
Bei mir ist jetzt gerade wieder grün geworden.
Ja gut. Wollen wir mal abwarten.
Aber du hast natürlich recht, also ist halt einfach klar. Äh wenn es komplett aus der Hand läuft, aber
Dazu muss man auch sagen, bevor das jetzt gleich wieder so als äh negative
und mittlerweile haben wir,
anderes Virus, was eine extrem viel höhere Infektions äh Tätigkeit nach sich zieht und da ist natürlich klar, dass das hier äh vielleicht nicht mehr in dem Maße skaliert.
Absolut denkbar.
Vor allem weil wir jetzt auch eine also das ist natürlich recht der Grund warum wir heute so ein hohes Infektionsgeschehen,
haben und tolerieren, ist, dass wir ein sehr viel ansteckenderes Virus haben, welches offenbar in der Summe,
zu weniger äh schweren Problemen für die Menschen, für die es befällt. Ja, das der Einzelfall mag abweichen, in der Summe können wir uns,
als Gesellschaft sehr viel höhere Infektionsraten leisten, ohne großartigen.
Ohne einen ohne das befürchtete Überlaufen der äh Krankenhausbetten und so weiter zu befürchten, ja? Ähm.
Und genau deshalb ist zumindest jetzt die Warnung keine.
Keine Seltenheit,
das ist das ist dann ja auch dann verliert diese gesamte App ihren Informationscharakter.
Und bei geniedrigerem Infektionsgeschehen, wo die rote Warnung eine Besonderheit ist, eine Seltenheit, ähm mit.
Notwendigen,
und so weiter. Ich meine, Lauterbach hat hier vor Kurzem äh für einen Tag wurde in Aussicht gestellt, man müsste noch nicht mal mehr sich in Isolation begeben, wenn man äh positiv ist Verhaltensänderungen, ja, teste dich, geh in Quarantäne.
Also wir haben eine ganz andere äh politische Situation. Das hat natürlich auch eine entsprechende Konsequenz für den Umgang der Menschen mit der Infektion
und ähm entsprechend äh glaube ich auch, dass die Zahlen gerade primär deshalb.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass Leute das so machen.
Ja klar, also äh das das Geschehen ist jetzt ein anderes und äh ich glaube man kann jetzt auch fast sagen.
Wir kommen wahrscheinlich jetzt schon so ans Ende der Nützlichkeit der.
Absolut, also ich würde sagen, also das tue ich. Ich sehe nicht ich würde sie nicht deinstallieren, weil das natürlich jetzt sein kann.
Noch was kommen. Es kann es kann ja immer noch wieder irgendein,
schlummerndes Delta irgendwie ausm äh aus irgendeinem Loch hervorgekrochen kommen und wieder die gesamte Omikronimmunität abräumen. Das ist,
nicht unbedingt jetzt besonders wahrscheinlich, aber
sagt man so schön, nach der Pandemie ist vor der Pandemie. Irgendwann wird es auch wieder eine Pandemie geben und da sind natürlich solche Systeme äh auch ein riesiger Informationsgewinn.
Der Zeitpunkt das ganze System jetzt abzuschalten ist sicherlich auch noch nicht gekommen, weil das Geschehen ist ja auch ähm,
sagen wir mal, die Betrachtung, die wir jetzt hier machen, ist eben eine deutsche Perspektive. Das gilt sicherlich für viele europäische Länder, aber äh in China zum Beispiel.
Gut, wurde jetzt diese Architektur nicht zum Einsatz kommt, aber theoretisch ja könnte, ähm,
Da ist halt noch genau diese Situation, dass man doch eine relativ naive also virus naive äh Bevölkerung hat, weil einfach Impfquote ist niedrig und die Impfungen, die dort ausgegeben wurde, auch teilweise
wohl nicht so gut funktioniert gegen von daher ist noch die Gefährdung extrem hoch und man hat sich dort ja sowieso,
zu einem ganz anderen Grundverhalten äh entschlossen oder zumindest wird dann ein anderes Grundverhalten durchgesetzt, also Lockdowns et cetera.
Na ja.
Also man kann es sicherlich gebrauchen, aber in der jetzigen Pandemiesituation würde ich vorsichtig vermuten, dass äh diese Corona-Warn-App nicht mehr in der Lage ist, einen,
nennenswerten Beitrag in ihrem Sinne zu leisten,
jemanden vorzeitig zu warnen, damit die Person keine anderen mehr anstecken. Äh du kannst jetzt
Geh doch mal irgendwie heute,
Wer hat denn keine? Ne? Also das das wird einfach die Situation ist jetzt eine andere. Ähm.
Aber es äh nach wie vor eine gute Info-App. Meine man kann die App öffnen und man sieht halt aktuelle Zahlen et cetera. Das ist dann halt irgendwie auch alles.
Ich will nicht sagen, also man muss nicht,
alles richtig, aber jetzt grade würde ich da mal die laufenden Kosten reduzieren. Das haben übrigens auch gemacht, unsere Freunde von,
Und die Luca-App,
hat ihre Kernfunktion eingestellt. Als ich das heute gesehen habe, ne? Das war hier so ein Artikel vom Maiskolter. Titel Luca App stellt Kernfunktion ein und ich habe Kernfusion gelesen,
dachte so jetzt reicht's aber ey, jetzt hast du wirklich alles so. Ja, wir machen Bezahlung und Krankenhau und hier und Payment und und Kernfusion, eine Kernfunktion.
Und das lasst ihr jetzt sein. Das Einzige, was wirklich sinnvoll gewesen wäre.
Ja weil na,
künftig könnte man damit bezahlen und Trinkgeld geben,
ja bezahlen und Trinkgeld geben. Also Payment ja keine so schlechte Idee und diese Nutzungsbasis irgendwie zu ähm,
ja zu verramschen, ja, die,
geschrieben.
Ursprünglich haben sie doch ganz stolz angekündigt, dass sie selbstverständlich weitermachen, ne. Also sie sind ja Idealisten, selbstverständlich machen sie es weiter, auch wenn die Verträge auslaufen
Sie ja schon gesagt, wir machen's kostenlos, ja? In der da hatte ich ja auch schon weit vorher äh vorhergesagt.
Ähm und als sie jetzt diese Neuausrichtung angekündigt haben äh nur das äh hat sich jetzt halt erledigt. Jetzt hat der,
Patrick Hennig, der Geschäftsführer in einem Video-Luca als eine der wenigen Erfolgsgeschichten in der Digitalisierung Deutschlands bezeichnen.
Dann wirklich gut.
Ein bisschen wie mit mir und der äh Müllhalde, ne, so in seiner Erinnerung sieht er auch nur Großtaten.
Mhm.
Ruf doch mal an, wenn du da so eine gute so gute Kontakte hast, das mit der Kernfusion ist doch eigentlich eine geil.
Wäre echt eine super Idee, ja. Ähm.
Da sollten Sie sich mal drum kümmer.
Genau, jetzt wollen sie für ein besseres Kundenerlebnis sorgen in der Gastronomie, ja?
Aber immerhin sie halten die Infrastruktur,
wer wer weiß, wo sie's gehostet hat, den machen sie jetzt mal aus. Kriegen sie jederzeit wieder an, ja. Ähm.
Schön finde ich, das von Kritikern bemängelte Luca äh System
Hits vor Angriffen stand, die Luca Macher konnten aber auch nicht verhindern, dass in einem Fall die Polizei in Mainz die Daten von Gästen widerrechtlich über das Gesundheitsamt abfragen ließ ähm und
glaube das war ein ist auch nicht bei einem Fall geblieben. Ja also,
können jetzt äh ihre Kosten runterfahren. Ich denke, die haben genug Kohle damit gemacht und äh ja, Warnung vor der,
Zweitverwertung, die jetzt auf jeden Fall kommen wird. Das ist so eine App, die kann man deinstallieren im Gegensatz zu Corona-Warn-App.
So, dann gab's Neuigkeiten von dieser ominösen Gruppe. Du weißt welche.
Gruppe.
Experten.
Die äußern sich ja von Zeit zu Zeit.
Experten waren im Bundestag. Auf einmal kriegen kriegen wir irgendwie Nachrichten hier so ausm Bundestag so ey Leute, wisst ihr was da los ist? Äh Anhörung, Fachgespräch zum E-Voting im Bundestag.
Und da geht der Bundeswahlleiter Georg Thiel.
Hin und sagt er würde jetzt mal vorschlagen, lass mal so ein bisschen Online Stimmabgabe macht.
Du bist Bundeswahl, Alter. Du hast einen Job? Ja und das wäre ja ein bisschen ärgerlich, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das ja 2009 verboten.
Hat er Recht, ja? Der hat seine Hausaufgaben gemacht. Er hat es erkannt, ja. Äh weil nämlich die Stimmabgabe öffentlich und Transparenz erfolgen muss. Ähm.
Und eben die Nachvollziehbarkeit gesichert werden muss. Also der hattet in Zügen.
Verstanden. Deswegen möchte er, glaube ich, auch nicht bei äh bei den wichtigen Wahlen wie Parlamentswahlen,
Onlinevoting machen, sondern bei kleineren Urnengängen außerhalb der großen Tanker,
Der kleinere Unengang. Stelle mir gerade so vor, wie man so, weißt du, so nebenbei Uhrengang, den du so, ne, warst der nicht so wichtig ist.
Auf dem Friedhof oder was.
Ja genau äh.
Möchte er denn gerne zu Grabe tragen? Also er möchte gerne das Prinzip von Wahlen zu Grabe tragen
das ist sozusagen der Umgang, der hier äh angetreten wird mit diesem Vorstoß, weil das ist einfach mal, ich.
Allerdings ne, er ist das schon kritisch. Er sagt, Bund und Länder schaffen es
deswegen wird er bei den politischen Wahlen kein Ende machen und wäre sehr skeptisch.
Okay, da immerhin.
Ja? Da es auch BSI-Richtlinien gibt. So da muss man aber mal kurz anmerken,
BSI-Richtlinien, die haben wir damals kritisiert. Die sind eine direkte Konsequenz von dem Bundestagswahl-Hack den Thorsten Schröder, Martin Schiersig und ich damals gemacht haben zwanzig siebzehn.
Als Konsequenz daraus hat das BSI dann eine Richtlinie geschrieben,
Diese Richtlinie bezieht sich aber kaum auf diese Wahl auswertungssoftware, sondern primär darauf, wie die Leute, die dieses wie die Computer bereitstellen, auf denen diese Software läuft,
das äh die die sichern müssen. Also mit anderen Worten.
Es gibt eine Schrottsoftware. Wir schreiben jetzt mal eine Richtlinie, was man alles machen muss, um diese Schrottsoftware zu benutzen. Ja? Ähm und,
viel weniger. Diese Software ist,
Was wir in diesem Online-Voting oder in dem Wahlauswertungsmarkt sehen, ist, die Unternehmen kaufen einander langsam selber auf und haben dann so einen Lobbyverband Interessengemeinschaft E-Woating.
Äh mit der Sie äh dann hier,
halt E-Voting-Kram machen, ja? Und dann jetzt hat er hier diese Fachgespräche sind immer gibt's also diesen Dienstleister VDI, VDE Innovation,
die machen,
ähm im Auftrag des Büros für Technikfolgenabschätzung. Da gab's auch mal so eine ähm so eine Bot-Diskussion, bei der ich war, ne? Und dann gehen die hin,
und schreiben dann so eine Studie und dann gibt's ein Fachgespräch im Bundestag und dann kann der Bundestag sich darüber informieren, ne. Hat erstmal keine gesetzgeberische Konsequenz. Dieses Bottgespräch war ähm,
Gilt als einer meiner etwas äh unterhaltsameren Auftritte. Ich hatte Lust, da mal äh frei zu sprechen.
Aber da fragt man sich natürlich auch, warum also die CCC ham Sie nicht gefragt.
Aber okay, könnte auch mit meinem meinem Einlassungen zu Social Bots äh zu tun haben. Also irgendjemand meinte dann noch, ja man könnte ja die die EID Killeranwendung.
Wäre jetzt äh E-Voting also beziehungsweise es wäre in äh Estland so gewesen, weil man,
Der Onlineausweis wäre deswegen beliebt geworden, weil man damit E-Wort hinmachen konnte. Ich kann mir das irgendwie nicht vorstellen,
die Leute hier sitzen und sagen, boah eigentlich will ich keinen Onlineausweis, aber wenn ich jetzt E-Voting damit machen kann, dann dann.
Ja vor allem Killer-App. Ich meine wie oft wählt man.
Der kleinere Umgang Tim, der kleine Umgang.
Ja, aber ich meine.
So ein Großer? Wenn du nur klein.
Das ist auch nix. Ist auch nicht so, dass du morgens aufwachst und denkst so, oh, heute muss ja echt mal ich will unbedingt mal wählen,
So einen inneren Drang, verspürst, oh jetzt jetzt wählen, jetzt machen wir mal mir so richtig.
Da widerspreche ich.
Alice Weidel und und Christian Lindner wählen. Das ist so.
Nee, ich würde gerne noch mal wählen. Also.
Aber das bist du und die meisten Leute denken sich so ey Wahlen ey, geh mir aus der Sonne. Aber so Dinge des täglichen Alltags. Ich meine so Bürgertermine in Berlin.
Kleinkram deinen neuen Pass beantragen.
Das ist die Killer-App. Ja natürlich. Auto anmelden wer die Killer-App, Leute. Oder at.
Ja so das geht ja auch teilweise schon in manchen Bundesländern. Da geht es tatsächlich mit diesem EID.
Die geben dann immer an bei uns in den Kommentaren.
Ja und überhaupt äh sich Bescheinigungen holen, all dieser ganze Zettelkram, wo man heutzutage halt einfach einen Termin mit irgendjemand ausmachen muss, was in Berlin bedeutet, wie in zwei Monaten.
Und das das das sind Killer Apps, weil Leute da wirklich einen Bedarf.
Ich,
Leute, echt.
Und äh einfach auch bitte
Onlinewahlen haltet euch einfach zurück. Das ist einfach bewiesen, dass es Unsinn ist und
Anreiz auch immer wieder triggert. Ne so dieses ich liebe Technologie, ich möchte gerne das Leben von allen Menschen einfacher machen,
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass das nicht irgendwie geht. Da muss man auch nur mal drüber nachdenken und dann kommen halt immer wieder so gerade die der aktuelle äh
Tischhalb
schläft das natürlich irgendwann wieder ein, weil sie einfach auch alles Quatsch ist und dann kommen irgendwie,
ne so oh ja, aber jetzt online, weil mit Blockchain geht das auf jeden Fall, ne? Aber nicht, weil die Leute der Meinung
oder nicht weil die.
Kann man das mit Brokkoli machen.
Da sollte man mal drüber nachdenken.
Die machen die die fahren das Land noch vor die vor die äh vor die Wand. Da musst du machst dir keine Sinn, machst dir nichts vor. Eine Blockchain und mit Cyber.
So nächstes Jahr, Renate Künast hat gegen Meta gewonnen. Vor Gericht. Das ist ja jetzt ich weiß Landgericht Frankfurt am Main,
Hintergrund ihr wird seid äh zweitausendfünfzehn glaube ich äh von unterschiedlichen Leuten ähm ein Zitat,
in den Mund,
das lautet, das ist ein Falschzitat, äh sie hätte gesagt, Integration fängt damit an, dass sie als Deutscher mal Türkisch lernen. Das ist ja auch ziemlich
unglaubwürdig, dass sie das gesagt hat und äh dieses Zitat wird immer wieder auf Facebook veröffentlicht, eben auch in Grafiken und,
Ähm jetzt hat sie ähm,
Rechtsstreit gegen Facebook gekämpft, über längere Zeit. Die haben wir auch immer regelmäßig mal hier berichtet, wo sie gesagt hat, okay, sie möchte.
Nicht jeder Einzelne dieser Vorkommnisse melden müssen, sondern sie möchte Regeln.
Haft von Facebook einfach die Verbreitung dieses Falschzitats verlangen können. Da stellt natürlich äh Facebook vor gewisse Herausforderungen. Hm könnte also in Richtung,
ähm ne Uploadfilter gehen, ja, das war auch die äh Kritik,
oder die Sorge, dass hier irgendwie Facebook versuchten oder gezwungen sein könnte, das mit ähm Uploadfiltern künstlicher Intelligenz und irgendwelchen Scherzen zu bekämpfen.
Und äh der äh es wird aber ähm.
In diesem Verfahren geht es nicht darum, den erneuten Upload zu verhindern, sondern äh zumindest plädiert auch die,
Juristin von hat dafür zu sagen na ja da muss halt Content Moderatorin eingesetzt werden und Menschen diese Entscheidung treffen. Ja dann kannst du natürlich sagen okay wir haben eine,
ein Renate Künast,
wie das ähm technisch umsetzbar sein soll,
und auch skalierend sein soll für Leute, die nicht Renate Künast sind und mit einem äh,
Anwalt, der äh sich nicht zum ersten Mal mit Facebook anlegt, halt eben über offenbar sechs, sieben Jahre äh dieses Thema beackern, weil es ja auch ein politisches für sie war. Ähm.
Was man nicht vergessen darf, ist die Person,
Also zu sagen, okay, geht gar nicht und man hat ja überhaupt gar keine Handhabe gegen Facebook und sie müssen jedes jeden einzelnen Vorkommnis selber melden. Hat natürlich jetzt auch
über die Jahre, wenn Renate Künitz sich da immer noch gegen Wert. Willst du nicht wissen, wie oft
diese Quatsch gepostet wurde und wie oft sie dann infolgedessen auch Ziel von Hasskommentaren waren, ne und wie hartnäckig hier auch eine Falschzitat äh verbreitet wird. Insofern,
Würde ich an dieser Stelle jetzt mal sagen, so ist wahrscheinlich erst mal ganz sinnvoll, Facebook mit diesem rechtlichen Anspruch zu konfrontieren.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Facebook sich einfallen lässt, um dem auch zu entsprechen. Da würde ich, wäre ich nicht so zuversichtlich.
Dass Facebook da jetzt eine sinnvolle äh Lösung so einfällt, die ihr bestenfalls auch noch mit Menschen zu tun hätte,
wäre ich nicht so zuversichtlich.
Nee, das äh trotzdem gute Entscheidung und ich hoffe, dass ich da nicht irgendwas bessert.
Mitbekommen, dass die dass die Mitarbeiter bei Facebook den Mark Zuckerberg äh Auge von Sauron nennen.
Aber er war sich ganz sicher, dass das liebevoll gemeint ist.
Oh man ey,
er ist auch der einzige Bewohner dieses Meterversums.
Loving Lea Calham, I also soron oder wie auch immer das so.
Der lebt echt im Metaversumm, davor irgendwie alle Menschen kein kein Unterleib haben.
Ja. Okay, ja, das war das.
Dann war das das auch mit dieser Sendung Linus, oder? Denke schon.
Tim du solltest echt mal aufhören immer so bei Blockchain und so. Das war wirklich lies dich lies dich da mal ein. Lies dich da mal ein.
Was zu reden oder zu raten? Erstmal richtig verstehen.
Lies sich auch gar nicht so schwer.
Oder die Chancen, die großen Chancen, die die das hat.
Nee, du musst ja, also du musst ja hier mit den Bits und mit den Bits und den Comes.
Weil weil Blockchain ja auch über Finanzen hinaus einfach auch eine eine goldene Zukunft hat, die zwar keiner so richtig benennen kann, aber.
Du bist vor den Leuten nicht sicher.
Und Open-Source auseinandersetzen. Das wäre alles.
Und aus es ist absolut ein Scheiß, ja irgendwelche Begriffe aneinandergesetzt,
Aber das wird die Revolution, ne. Das war Content. Ich habe gedacht, die,
Ich habe echt gedacht, so okay komm, das ist jetzt so lächerlich, dass dass irgendwelche Leute verstecken, Kamera.
Die mich irgendwie ärgern wollen. Die sagen so, komm mach mal. Setzen wir uns,
So so ein
Ist das so lächerlich, so erbärmlich? Und erkennbar,
Oh das oh war das schwierig. Er war schwierig. Er war ganz schön belastend.
Du bist nirgendwo vor den sicher.
Nee, Busse mussten dackbar Rakete reinschicken. Was hilft?
So tschüss.
Tschüss, bis bald.